[Music]
we searched far and wide to find the
geekiest Jews in the entire universe and
here they are the Vibram FiveFingers
these are sort of like little plastic
foot gloves and they're designed to help
you run as if you were barefoot you
might not think that running barefoot is
an especially smart thing to do after
all we're used to thinking of the
padding that most shoes have as
providing essential support without
which your feet are going to get injured
there's a growing body of research that
suggests running barefoot is exactly the
way your body was designed to work the
way your leg and foot are designed
they're actually excellent shock
absorbers on their own so when your foot
hits the ground for example the arch in
your foot flattens out and then springs
back up to the arch like shape as you
take your next step a traditional
running shoe like this Brooks trance has
a really fat heel and what that
encourages you to do when you're running
is hit heel first so your heel strikes
the ground and then it rolls forward
onto the front part of your foot
that means the cushion absorbs some of
the impact but your leg is absorbing a
lot v broom has been making soles for
other shoes for decades and the five
fingers is kind of like a stripped-down
shoe with nothing but the sole or the
sole plus just a little bit more it's
got a flexible kind of rubber plastic
bottom and just a little bit of fabric
on the top helped hold your toes on each
of the toes has its own little pocket
which gives you a really kind of comfy
snug feeling when you're wearing it but
it also kind of freaks out some people
who think that it looks really weird be
broom has even cut little tiny grooves
in the sole of the foot lots of tire
manufacturers do this too they cut these
zigzag grooves called sipes into their
tires and Vibram has done this to give
these shoes extra traction the five
fingers cost between 75 and 85 dollars
now whether that seems like a lot of
money or a little money to you depends
on how you feel about barefoot running
ideally you should just be able to kick
off your shoes and run outside with
naked feet and that would be totally
free on the other hand if you want to
protect your feet against cuts and
scrapes and stepping the dog to another
now
see stuff like that the five fingers do
a great job and they definitely cost
less than a high-end pair of running
shoes they'll probably last a lot longer
too
so if we're running in a very natural
way this is a great way to do it
[Music]